في الاستديو اساميه ال اا خالد الغرابلي
خالد مرحبا واهلا بك خالد هناك خبر نشر في
صحيفه نيويورك الامريكيه عن انه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ترسل اسلحه ومساعده
عسكريه الى اوكرانيا عبر مخازن اسلحه
موجوده لديها في اسرائيل
بدايه ما قصت هذه المخازن المخازن الاسلحه
الامريكيه الموجوده هناك ما كشفته نيويورك
تايمز يتحدث عن نقل ذخيره وتحديدا قذائف
من عيار 155 ملم نحو ثلاثمائه الف قذيفه
تم الاتفاق على ان تقوم الولايات المتحده
بسحبها من مخازن لها في اسرائيل لنقلها
الى اوكرانيا لاحقا قصه المخازن خلال حرب
عام ثلاثه و70 التي تواجهت فيها مصر
وسوريا من جهه واسرائيل من جهه اخرى
اسرائيل تكبدت خسائر كبيره في هذه الحرب
من ما دفع الولايات المتحده الى القيام
بجسر جوي لتعويض الخسائر الاسرائيليه
والروس من جهتهم قاموا بالجسر همم جوي مع
حلفاءهم لكن يبدو انه بعد هذه الحرب تعلم
الامريكيون والاسراليون الدرس منها وتم
الاتفاق بين الجانبين على ما سمي في مذكره
استراتيجيه لم تعلم سمي التموضع المسبق
بمعنى تم الاتفاق في الثمانينات على ارسال
اسلحه امريكيه دبابات ومدرعات توضع في
صحراء النقب وفي اكثر من قاعده وبعد ذلك
مع الوقت تم توسيع هذه المذكره لتشمل
ذخائر للدبابات والمضارعات لكن ايضا ذخائر
للقوات الجويه وذخائر للقوات البحريه
لتكون جاهزه للاستخدام عند الحاجه اي حاجه
تحديدا نص المذكره هو الذي سيحدد لكن ما
فهيمه انه عند الحاجه الاسرائيليه لهذا
السلاح لان بعض المصادر الامريكيه تتحدث
عند حجه الولايات المتحده نفسها مع العلم
طبعا عن الولايات المتحده لها الكثير من
القواعد في المنطقه من الواضح ان الهدف من
ايجاد هذه المخا هو تلبيه الحاجه
الاسرائيليه وتم السماح لاسرائيل باستخدام
همم ذخيره من من هذه المخازن همم في 2006
اثناء الحرب على لبنان وفي 2014 اثناء
الحرب على قطاع غزه
واليوم عندما نسمع ان الاتفاق يتعلق بثلاث
مئه الف قذيفه من عيار 155 ملم نتوقع حجم
الذخيره والسلاح الموجود ربما في هذه
المخازن لا توجد تفاصيل عن نوعيه وحجم
الاسلحه الموجوده لكن ما كشف من خلال
المصادر الامريكيه والاسرائيليه نيو تايمز
ان الولايات المتحده تعاهدت ان ما يتم
سحبه من هذه المخازن سيتم تعويضه وان كانت
هناك حاجه انيه سيتم تقديم هذه الذخيره
بشكل الانيميا
بحسب المصادر التي تحدثت في نيويورك تايمز
لان هذه تحتاج الى معلومات وليس تحليل
الجانب الاوكراني يستهلك نحو 90 الف قذيفه
من فئه 155 ملي متر في الشهر 90000 قذيفه
هذا ضعف ما تنتجه المصانع الامريكيه
والاوروبيه مجتمعه في الشهر
الى هذه الذخيره هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى
حاله الجمود على معظم الجبهه الان تجعل
المواجهه هي من خلال مدفعيه والاهم
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده هو التحضير
لمعركه الربيع الولايات المتحده تريد
توفير القذائف التي ستكون مهمه في تحديد
مسار الحرب بالاضافه طبعا الى هناك
اجتماعات مع حلف الاطلسي في الايام
المقبله ليتم تزويد الاوكرانيين دبابات
اساسيه وليس فقط الدبابات
الخفيفه او المدرعات ان كانت فرنسيه او
امريكيه او المانيه رغ في تسليم دبابات
بريطانيه دبابه الاساسيه في الجيش
البريطاني تشالنجر اثنان بالاضافه طبعا
الى اليوبار اثنان الدبابه الرئيسيه في
الجيش الالماني والتي توصف على مستوى
العالم بانها واحده من افضل الدبابات في
العالم الولايات المتحده تريد التحضير
لمعركه الربيع لتحريك الامور لانه ان لم
تتحرك الامور هذا العام العام المقبل هناك
انتخابات امريكيه واهم دوله داعمه
لاوكرانيا ستكون مشغوله بانتخابات وان جاء
جمهوريون بعد ذلك بعد هذه الانتخابات
سيكون الدعم الامريكي الاوكرانيا مشكوك
فيه وبالتالي ما يحدث الان هو نوع من
التحضير المشكله الان انه دائما بحسب
انهيار تايمز ان ال- ال- الامريكيين
اكتشفوا ان الاوكرانيين لا يحسنون استخدام
المدافع التي قدمت لهم حتى ان هناك
تقديرات بان ثلث هذه المدافع التي سلمت من
الامريكيين والدول الغربيه اصبح خارج
الخدمه وانا هناك استخدام مبالغ فيه من
جانب الاوك وبالتالي هناك محاوله لتدريب
الاوكرانيين نصائح وتوجيهات لتكون
الاستخدام اكثر حكمه لهذه القذائب
بالاضافه الى طبعا مساعده الاوكرانيين
بمنظومات اكثر دقه هاي مارس صواريخ التي
توجه همم بشكل اكثر دقه لتكون اكثر فعاليه
ويكون هناك ما يكفي من الذخيره لتحقيق
نتائجها على الارض طيب خالد طالما تعرضت
اوكرانيا او انه ارسال مساعده عسكريه همم
لها ما الذي يتغير في الموقف الاسرائيلي
اليوم ولماذا في تقرير الاستراليون يضربون
همم اكثر من عصور بحجر واحد اولا يتخلصون
من الضغوط الاوكرانيه دائما كانت تطالب
اوكرانيا بتقديم همم اسلحه وكان
الاسرائيليون يترددون يتقدمون بمساعده
انسانيه اكثر من اي شيء اخر لانهم يخافون
الغضب الروسي ان غضبت روسيا ستمنع على
طيران الاسرائيلي الدخول اجواء السوريه
اللي ضرب اهداف سوريا وايرانيه
والاسرائيليين يريدون الاستمرار في منع من
التموضع في سوريا وبالتالي كانت تحول همم
تفادي هذه المواجهه مع روسيا خاصه امام
بدر قال ان العلاقات ستنسف ان كان هناك
تقديم من اسلحه اساسيه من جانب اسرائيل
لاوكرانيا فكان هناك رفض الان اسرائيل
ماذا تقول تقول هذا سلاح امريكي
بس همم الامريكي ليسوا في حاجه
اسرائيليه لكي يسحب هذا السلاح من مخازنهم
هم من جهه يتخلصون من الضغط الاوكراني من
جهه اخرى لا يغضبون اجانب الامريكي وهناك
بعض ال- ال- ال- المصادر العسكريه التي
تتحدث عن طلبات اسرائيليه كنوع من
المقايضه بمعنى اخذتم هذه الكميه من
الذخيره عليكم
تدعمونا بذخائر تستخدم ضد الانفاق ممكن ان
تستخدم في اي حرب مقبله مع غزه وممكن ان
تستخدم في حاله توجيه ايضا لايران
وبالتالي تستفيد حتى في همم همم في الحصول
على اسلحه اوروبا ما لم تكن موجوده في
المخازن الامريكيه في اسرائيل وفي النهايه
تقول ال- ال- يقول الان يقول مسؤولون
اسرائيليون هذا ليس قرار اسرائيلي هذا
قرار امريكي سلاح امريكي والقرار امريكي
وليس لنا اذان في هذا الموضوع ولكن طبعا
هناك الكثير من مؤشرات
يوحي بان الامور القرار هو قرار
الاسرائيلي امريكي مشترك صحيح نص
الاتفاقيه بين الطرفين غير معلن وبالتالي
لا نستطيع ان نعرف بوضوح لكن هناك مؤشرات
الجانب كشفت انها وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
طلب بشكل رسمي من نظير الاسرائيلي صاحب
هذه الكميه من القذائف لو لم تكن لو
القرار الامريكي بحث لم تكن امريكا مضطره
الى تقديم طلب رسمي الى جانب الاسرائيلي
الاسرائيليين اجتمعوا بحثوا الموضوع وبعد
ذلك وافقوا على اعتبار ان السلاح همم
امريكي لو لم يكن هناك ضروره فقد
اسرائيليه كان الامريكيون انسحبوا السلاح
منذ ان خدم طلب منذ اشهر وليس همم في
الفتره الاخيره اذا همم هذا هذه مؤشرات
مؤشر اخر هذا السلاح عندما وضع في اسرائيل
وضع لحمايه اسرائيل اهم حليب للولايات
المتحده فمن المنطقي ايضا ان الولايات
المتحده ان ارادت سحب الذخيره التي توفر
هذه الحمايه ان تتشاور مع جانب الاسرائيلي
اهم حليف لها ومن هنا نفهم هناك مشاورات
مع جانب الاسرائيلي وفي النهايه الولايات
المتحده لم تسحب هذا هذه الاخيره الا بعد
موافقه
هذا دوله اسرائيل وهذا يوحي طبعا انا
لاسرائيل ااا ااا يد وسلطه في عمليه اتخاذ
القرار شكرا جزيلا لك اسامي الخالد الغرام
اللي على هذه المدخنه